our next speaker
I actually introduced him and his wife
at their wedding at MCU introduced them
and I almost messed up his wife's name a
really bad slip up
but crucially Max is also I just last
name but he's also a professional gummy
mule a gummy sorry a professional gummy
bear mule he snuck them across borders
for me everyone please welcome Max
uh thanks for waiting around to the
second to last uh talk here at the
conference I appreciate that
um nobody will probably be surprised
that I will be talking about modeling I
think I said that last year too
so the idea is this um something I've
been working on lately I should stay up
front that a person I work with deposit
named Edgar Ruiz did most of like the
like the programming on this so he and I
worked together on this for like six
months the idea is the model behind the
model to fix like the first model and
hopefully that'll come across well here
so you know I was trying to think of
like how I could start this and it's
sort of like the idea that you know you
have a data set
um you do all this work and sometimes
they're very difficult and you find you
know a small handful of models that if
you tune them just right actually get
pretty good performance which is not
really how it usually is
um in this particular data set it was
like 1500 data points and 56 predictors
and a model that seemed to work pretty
well with something called a naive Bayes
model and I had an air into the RC curve
of
0.86 and there it is right there so you
think like oh yeah this is really
awesome it's great
um but you know a college professor of
mine told me that the only way to be
comfortable with your data is never to
look at it
so then you know they start plotting
things and what I did is I took sort of
I did as you'll see in a minute some
resampling and these are the outer
sample predictions and that um a ggplot
on the right basically has things fasted
by the true class of this data and so on
the top you see that there's a big bar
there at one in a smaller bar at zero
it's basically bimodal uh and the
converse happens for the the no event
date on the bottom
um but it's kind of weird it's kind of
like a skeevy distribution you wouldn't
expect this to happen
um in fact in a lot of cases uh when you
predict it wrong you're like really
confidently incorrect so this is not
good this is you know it's something
where the model is separating the class
as well but not in any realistic way
once you start looking at the
probabilities that it generates and so
when we think about this is well the way
really the thing about this is that the
model is not very well calibrated and
calibration essentially means that if
you had an individual data point and its
prediction is like 80 percent like if
you had like a Marvel MCU way to like
alternate reality this thing like a
thousand times you would expect the
actual event to occur about eight
percent of the time so you know we don't
have a situation here with the um the
probability the underlying probability
then is probably not being well
estimated about account by the
probabilities
all right so before I continue uh just
share some tiny models code I'm not
going to go through this the only things
I want to highlight are basically that
we did cross validation using this
v-fold CV and at the bottom here is the
code where we actually fit the mod or
resample the model so you'll see these
Bays result object used and it basically
is the results of cross validation so
that whole that contains all of our
holdout predictions every time we did
the the tenfold cross validation it's
just a little technical note
so uh so a while back like a long time
ago I wrote this package called probably
and probably was mostly sort of like a
placeholder that had a few things in it
we had some things about uh equivalent
zones in there and then some tools that
will help you estimate appropriate
probability thresholds for
classification models and it kind of sat
for a while we didn't really have time
to do much with it and we've kind of
like done a lot with it over the last
year I mentioned Edgar and I worked on
calibration tools that are in probably
that's what we're going to talk about I
just more recently added some conformal
inference things to get prediction
intervals this is kind of like a hot
research topic right now so we're going
to look at calibration and all this
stuff is in the probably package and the
URL for this is at the bottom so if you
want to reproduce all this and see how
it works you can get the code
all right so let's look back at this
histogram I had earlier
um it's as I mentioned like you need
like alternate reality to see if any one
individual data point is well calibrated
but actually you can view the collection
of data points and find ways to figure
out if they are well calibrated or not
this is a really old technique so it's
nothing new but what I did is those
vertical dotted lines basically are the
are the data points that represent
um probabilities estimated probabilities
of less than 10 percent so if we look at
data and order them by their probability
of the event and let's just break that I
you know I hate binning but let's bend
it into 10 groups based on their
estimated probabilities and so if the
bottom is zero and the the top is ten
percent sort of the midpoint is is five
percent and if the models well
calibrated you expect about five percent
of your actual like labeled data to be
the event of interest and so what you
can do is you can do this let's say for
10 different bins and see if it lines up
with what you would expect it to be just
by chance and so this is the typical
calibration plot you see the code on the
left the code here is really boring I'm
going to have like some really cool
looking pipe things but we made the the
code pretty simple so we optimize uh
function names for tab complete so all
these things start with Cal for
calibration so we have a bunch of
plotting functions and you can see here
on the right that like that first dot on
the left is is the results of that bin
that I shared where you think if the
model were all calibrated that that data
point should be at one for both of those
axes but it's not so it's really like
overestimating the probability and then
you can see um it sort of meanders in
the middle and gets a little bit well
calibrated towards the end there but
this is this is about as bad as it gets
honestly and you know no shocker I
choose a knife base model for this
particular reason that with naive Bayes
if you have too many predictors and
those predictors are highly correlated
which they are in this data set you're
likely to get this sort of like bathtub
shaped or u-shaped distribution of your
probabilities so that wasn't an accident
for me
um so you know one one issue with this
plot is like well that's 10 bins should
I have used 20 should I use five and so
another way to do this is take 10 bins
and just do like a moving window so we
have that um which I think is a little
better than the other plot so you can
see that yeah the the bad trend is still
there despite you know how frequently
we've been them and then another we can
do this is we can take the data you know
the original data here and build a
logistic regression model and if our
logistic regression model the predictive
probabilities from that if the model the
original model is well calibrated the
predictions from that logistic model
should be on that diagonal line so we
have another function that will do that
using splines so it's basically a
generalized additive model and you can
see the same Trend here with some
confidence bounce on it so in other
words this model is like performance is
good in terms of Separation but in terms
of probabilities it's it's not great at
all
so what do we do about that well it
turns out that this isn't like you know
this wouldn't be my first choice we were
discussing this in the workshop the
other day my first choice would maybe be
is there a model that can give me
performances close to this but does have
good calibration properties but if you
can't find that or if there's some
reason like this model is more efficient
or you just like it what you can do is
you can build another model on top of it
that will basically fix the problem and
so all these tools what they basically
do is they try to estimate these trends
like you could take this logistic
regression and when you get new samples
like you know if you think if this curve
shows at some point you're
overestimating the probability of the
event by like 50 you can basically pull
that out you can basically pull it down
by roughly that amount so that it
basically you can coerce these
probabilities of fit along that that
diagonal line and so one of the the
classic ways of doing this is do
logistic calibration where you fit this
model and then when you get new
probabilities you basically deconvolute
it so it does actually comply with like
the the event rate you think should be
there another thing is that's pretty
useful is isotonic regression which is a
way to do monotonic
um like you know these this trend should
be increasing right it shouldn't like be
going wiggling around
um and so what isotonic regression is
like a regression model that ensures
that you have like a completely
increasing relationship or a complete
decreasing relationship now one side
downside to using the isotonic
regression is if you have like a
thousand like unique probabilities in
your model isotonic regression May
convert that to like 50 in the end so it
can kind of discretize your um your
model output so one thing that we did
that seemed to do better there is just
to bootstrap that like 50 times and so
if you've used isotonic regression and
uh and you use a bootstrap on that you
can you can sort of reduce it the
problem of it only giving you a few
predicted values and another tool that
um like if any of you know much page
analysis the beta distribution is
frequently used when looking at data
between zero and one it's the conjugate
prior for the um
for the binomial and so there are tools
using the beta distribution to estimate
certain quantities of beta distributions
to sort of fix this calibration problem
and we'll we'll look even though I won't
go into the details of it we'll look
mostly at the results a bit of
calibration
and so um so one other question about
this as I was thinking about is like
wait what data are we using you know
we're always saying like don't reproduct
your training set and start doing things
with that
um what we'll do here is we'll use the
the holdout sets from Cross Foundation
those predictions should be pretty
accurate we'll do use those to estimate
these trends that we want to pull out
and refactor out of the data ideally
what you'd like to do is you'd like to
pre-plan for this and if you have enough
data hold some of that data back just
for calibration so like the first job I
had was a molecular diagnostic company
and I would work on the assay
development but I was one of also the
people who built what they call the
algorithms for the instruments and
algorithm is maybe a little bit more
like sophisticated than what we actually
did most of the time but what we would
do is we would have clinical trials that
we would collect all the data that was a
substrate for our algorithms and then
why we did that work they would
continually accruing samples that we
would basically use for calibration
because when we went to FDA we had to
show them that this was well calibrated
with the actual event and so so if you
do have the chance to set aside data for
calibration it's probably the best thing
you could do
so then the other question is like well
how do we measure calibration because
clearly the RC curve didn't do that well
one thing you do is use something called
The Briar score and it's a score that's
been around for quite a long time if you
look at the equation of it it's almost
like sum to squared error for binary
data and when I first saw it I was like
well that why would you do that that
doesn't seem like a good idea but it
turns out that there's a lot of theory
behind this that the nature of this
statistical measure of performance is
actually quite good in fact it's better
than a lot of other things and so I've
sort of come around to maybe the bar
score being something that we should be
using just by default to measure how
well classification models do
so it's it's almost like an error
estimate for account for classification
so the best value you can get is zero so
you want to minimize it and for two CL
it depends on how many classes you have
to figure out like where the line of oh
God this is awful is for two classes if
you get a broader score about 0.25
you're not in doing well so um so for
that's what the situation we're in here
so that's sort of like the line of of
not like the Dignity of like a disaster
so
all right so a little bit more tiny
models code
we can look at how these models work we
can actually do the beta calibration but
what we didn't want to do is have people
do the calibration just start applying
it to their data set because we need
sort of like a second way to evaluate
when the calibration works or not we
don't want them continually repredicting
the test set and things like that so
what we did is we have these Cal
validate functions for the different
methods of calibration and you can give
it your original data like in that first
argument and then you can give it some
optional metrics to measure and what it
does is in this case we did tenfold
cross foundation so we have all those
predictions so we would use like 90
percent of this predictions to estimate
the beta calibration and then apply that
to the other 10 and compute our
performance metrics and then go sort of
round robin so it's basically cross
validation for calibration and when you
do the The Collection function it gives
you the results basically you can see
the results uh both for the brighter
score and the RSP curve you see the bar
score goes from about 0.21 and after
it's calibrated to about Point uh let's
see it's 0.145 so that's you know
numerically that's a nice Improvement
it's like a quarter better you might
notice the RC curve doesn't really
change at all even though standard error
is a little bit different most these
calibration methods they just sort of
change the rank order of the predictors
they change their probability values but
they usually do it in a fairly linear
linearish way so it doesn't surprise me
things like accuracy or well maybe not
accuracy but like log likelihood or the
air into the RC curve and things like
that aren't really drastically affected
or not affected At All by calibration so
the thing that we care about calibration
looks like we've improved it but we
haven't really hurt the uh the
separation aspect of this model by doing
this and so we have all these validation
functions for all the different methods
so typically I didn't do it here uh you
would just go around Robin and see which
one you like or which one gives you the
best performance using resampling and
that's probably the best way to choose
and in in this case beta did the best so
what we do in the last line there line
12 is we do like a final estimate that
takes the entire training sets to the
predictions the ones that were held out
computes all the the beta statistics
from that data set and that's what
you'll use going forward whenever you
process a test ad or new sample some
things like that
so looking to test that this is sort of
like a manual way in tiny miles to do it
you could fit your United baseball model
and the entire data training set and
then augment will then
um would then make those predictions uh
attach it to the original test set for
example and then we have a data frame
there on the left MB pred that has like
the raw predictions from the naive Bayes
model you can see our statistics there
are very consistent with what the
resampling gave us the Briar score is
like 0.22 which is verging on disaster
and then the RC curve is actually pretty
good when we want to apply the
calibration what we would do is we have
a function called Cal apply so you can
give it any of the calibration objects
and give it your predictions and now you
have sort of like the fixed version of
those probabilities and then we apply
the same estimates now the prior score
goes down to 0.15 we estimated from
resampling be about 0.14 and again the
RC score looks pretty good and this is
the test that results and then if we
wanted to see how it looked in our plots
well look it looks really well
calibrated at this point it's a little
bit off in a few little places but this
is just like Head and Shoulders above
what we were using earlier
and so um so basically like this is the
gist of like how you would do this in
tiny models
um it's something you know somebody in
the workshop asked me if I've ever done
this and I was like well no I've never
done this for other models but then I've
never really had the tools to do it
either so um so now you have tools to do
this if it if it works well we also have
um tools for multi-class models like
three or more classes and also for
regression models so if you have a
regression model where you plot like The
Observers is predicted and they sort of
like fan off on the end and you can't
find a way to fix that
um as sort of like maybe not a last
resort but you know you could use a
similar way to sort of like unbend that
curve using calibration
so you know now you have this
calibration object you have your
original model fit
um you know the code I showed here is
right now how you would apply the
calibration that's a little bit more
um work that that you we want you to
have to do so um what we're doing next
is
um we have these objects in in tiny
models called workflows you can think of
them as like scikit learn pipelines but
Hadley was like no don't use the word
pipeline
um and so what what workloads do is you
can bind together a preprocessor like a
recipe like Emily talked about recipes
earlier a little bit so you can take a
preprocessor or object in whatever model
you're trying to fit and you can combine
them into one object and so next on our
list is to add post-processing
objects to the workflow so whether it's
calibration or optimizing your
probability threshold for like a
two-class system or a variety of things
you might do to your data due to your
predictions after you fit your model
you'll be able to sort of attach like a
calibration object so when you use the
fit or the predict function at the very
end you don't have to do this extra step
of holding onto this extra object to
then transform your probabilities could
be built into the workload and that'll
be a nice little workflow or nice little
like usability feature for people
um we're on we're on a little bit of
minutiae here like we try to convince
everybody to resample everything right
that's like our Mantra is if you want to
get good performance statistics you have
to resample everything and uh and so
when you use a workflow when you
resample it that the workflow does any
sort of like interesting estimation
Parts like feature hashing or some like
complicated preprocessor we want to make
sure that gets executed every time
freshly with resampling just the same
way the model does
um in in for the post processor that's
mostly true but we're not really exactly
sure how to make that happen with
calibration because if you only have 10
of your data held out in that original
process like it's weird like when we we
cross validated the calibration earlier
we had the 90 of the prediction that
were held out to do the calibration to
then apply to the 10 that are most
recently held out in compute performance
and when we just do normal cross
validation for models and pre-processor
which is a little bit the opposite so
we're not really sure how we're going to
make that work yet
um but we will figure it out because
during regular cross validation you only
have 10 held out at any time you don't
have any of the other data to do the
calibration to then measure it so it
might take a little bit of work for us
to get this going with resampling but I
think using calibration and workflow
objects should be hopefully before the
end of the year so so that's what's on
Deck thanks for sticking around and just
to remind you uh Edgar Ruiz did most of
the the grunt work on this and so we
appreciate all the help that he gave
thanks
[Applause]